these cases are arguably the most
serious legal threat that the Bitcoin
Community has ever faced and even though
each of these cases is nominally about
Bitcoin they are more fundamentally an
attack on open source software and
Basics rights that are as fundamental as
freedom of speech
[Music]
all right guys bang bang I've got Jess
here with me Jess I thought that a great
place for us to start this conversation
would just be around the idea of using
the courts against open source software
what is the history of people trying to
do this and what are some of the
implications maybe of the current
environment of Open Source software
that's actually been driven by past
Court decisions
yeah that's a great question so you know
I think part of the thing that we're
dealing with uh at the Bitcoin legal
defense fund is
understanding that at any point anybody
can bring a lawsuit for anything right
but if a lawsuit is frivolous uh
typically those lawsuits don't survive
the issue becomes when somebody brings a
lawsuit that is arguably frivolous and
they have the financial means to run
with it the court systems are abused by
people who have the means to abuse them
and in this case we're dealing with
somebody who has brought a series of
lawsuits against a group of Bitcoin core
developers
um that have really created an
existential threat to open source
software development so I'd love to take
a little bit of time and walk you
through what these cases are about and
what the potential implications are for
open source software let's do it
go ahead let's do it go ahead yeah so
the fun that I work for the Bitcoin
legal defense fund it was established in
2021 by Jack Dorsey Martin white and
Alex morkos to support Bitcoin
developers who are facing legal battles
for the work that they do on bitcoin
core
um but the fund is fighting for more
than just Bitcoin it's fighting for the
right for developers to create open
source software without fear of legal
retaliation right now we're supporting
13 Bitcoin core developers across two
cases in the UK that have been brought
against them by Craig Wright or
companies that he controls right is
Infamous for litigating against members
of the Bitcoin community and I think
there's a tendency for people to kind of
just dismiss these attacks as unserious
because of who's behind them but we need
to take these cases in the UK extremely
seriously because if the courts rule
against the Bitcoin developers in these
cases it would have a chilling effect on
all open source software development
so turning to the first case which is
the case that's known as tool trading
the origins of this case are that Craig
Wright claims to have lost a hundred and
eleven thousand Bitcoin in this Ocean's
11 style hack
the first thing to make clear is that
there's no evidence that any of this
actually happened uh there's no evidence
that he owned any of this Bitcoin and
there's no evidence that he was hacked
nevertheless that did not stop him from
issuing a demand letter to several
Bitcoin core developers claiming that
they have a duty to stop illegitimate
transactions from occurring on the
network
tool trading filed this lawsuit in 2021
in the UK against 12 Bitcoin core
developers asking the court to legally
compel these devs to introduce a back
door to the Bitcoin core client that
would allow Wright to recover the
Bitcoin he claims to have owned and
claims to have lost
it's an absurd claim and the UK courts
initially agreed
the in the lower court in the UK
initially dismissed this lawsuit finding
that tool trading had not established a
serious issue of fact to be tried
right appeal that decision and a
three-judge appellate panel at the
second highest court in the UK found in
fact that it was a serious issue that
the court needed to evaluate at a full
trial so the question that the courts
are now grappling with in the UK is
whether
decentralization of Bitcoin is really a
myth
and more importantly the question of
whether open source developers not just
Bitcoin developers should owe a
fiduciary duty to people who use
software that they create let's take
those two things right there right
um decentralization why is that an
important thing that they're grappling
with because if it is fully
decentralized then no one person could
be held responsible for introducing back
doors or anything like that or like what
is the exact uh kind of debate around
why decentralization is so important
here
I think ultimately it's just a myth a
misunderstanding that the the courts
have as to how Bitcoin functions and I
think that's something that we'll be
able to clarify throughout the course of
this trial I do think that question is
potentially a bigger issue for some
other uh protocols or you know
cryptocurrencies
Etc because what the court is
considering when they are considering
decentralization is whether there is an
element of control
and I think that is what the courts are
interested in whether there is one
person or group of people who control
whatever the protocol is that's not the
case in Bitcoin the the devs the
maintainers they don't control Bitcoin
nobody controls Bitcoin if you were to
say there's a person who controls
Bitcoin it is each and every single
person who selects what type of Bitcoin
client they're going to run so you know
I think fundamentally that question is
just a misunderstanding of how Bitcoin
works that question that the court is
asking but I do think it you know should
raise the hackles of maybe people who
work in other types of
protocols or software that maybe there
is some level of centralization there is
an opportunity for somebody to come in
and save a person or write a back door
in that's not the case with Bitcoin but
it is a question that the court is
curious about and I think for those
reasons that I articulated the question
of whether there is an opportunity to to
control got it and then talk about the
open source developers having a
fiduciary duty to people who use the
open source software that seems on its
face to be kind of ridiculous but uh the
courts aren't in the business of
narratives they're much more in the
business of facts and kind of precedent
and things like that and so what are
some of the things people should be
aware of uh in terms of that specific
argument
yeah so I think it's important to first
uh describe to your listeners
um what fiduciary duty is because
although I'm a lawyer and I sort of have
spent quite a lot of time living and
breathing this not everybody is is
conversant of all uh with all the
different duties that exist under the
law uh fiduciary duty is a
well-established legal Duty that arises
in certain contractual or legal
relationships it is the strongest duty
of care that exists under the law the UK
courts have defined fiduciary duty as a
duty of single-minded loyalty what this
means in practice is that the fiduciary
is obligated either by law or by
contract put to put their principles
best interests above all others
including their own this is an
exceptional obligation and it goes far
beyond any ordinary duty of care to deal
honestly or without negligence some
examples of uh real fiduciary
relationships that exist under the law
are a lawyer has a fiduciary duty to
their client a doctor to their patient a
corporate board to their shareholders so
fiduciary duty is a real Duty that
exists on the law it is an important one
but it doesn't apply in this situation
it doesn't make any practical sense
and the reason for that is because it is
absurd to consider that any one or group
of Open Source developers could ever owe
this duty of single-minded loyalty to
potentially millions of strangers all
over the world who use their code there
is no Nexus between the software
developer and some unknown end user
there is no connection How could a
software developer write in code in
Texas have any idea what would be in the
best interest of some unknown end user
who uses their code way down the line so
that's the question that the court is
grappling with and the court said
in the Appel decision it rendered
earlier this year it acknowledges that
this is not a real application or or
um
uh an apparent application of fiduciary
duty it acknowledges that this would be
a departure from the hundreds of years
of existing law
but it is considering whether this is a
step the court would need to take and I
think for those of us who are paying
close attention to this and and I hope
now all of us are paying close attention
to this I think that is the most
concerning piece this is a very
intelligent group of Judges who spent
quite a lot of time thinking about this
this was not just an overall Miss what
they said was that this is a departure
this is not where fiduciary duty lies or
has historically ever lie but
they need to consider whether in this
changing ecosystem it makes sense and
part of our job as the representatives
of these devs is to show the court no it
doesn't make any sense it's illogical
it's impractical and it's inapplicable I
have no idea how this could actually be
effectuated in practice
so Jess before we move on to the other
cases uh explain a little bit about the
Bitcoin legal defense fund and kind of
like your old's role because I think
people will hear what you're talking
about and say okay cool there's this
case going on uh it's very important uh
there's a lot of nuance here she sounds
like she knows what she's talking about
right and is making a compelling case uh
who are they why are they the ones who
are going and fighting this who who kind
of put them up to do this uh so describe
a little bit about the the legal defense
fund
I'm so glad you asked so the legal
defense fund is a non-profit that was
established a couple of years ago
um in response to this case that we've
been discussing this tool trading case
it was founded by uh Jack Dorsey Alex
Marcos and Martin white
um to fight back because essentially
what's going on is Craig Wright sued a a
group of Bitcoin core devs and he's
banking that these devs might not be
able to adequately defend themselves
litigation is incredibly expensive and
he's being bankrolled by a billionaire
so that's why the fund is here the fund
is here to Fat fight back we provide
funding litigation strategy and serve if
you will sort of as in-house de facto
in-house counsel for these 13 developers
who are subject to excuse me this
lawsuit so that's what we're here to do
but it's not just that we provide
funding of course that's a very
important component of this you know in
order to defend yourself in a lawsuit
you need to be able to pay your lawyers
you need to be able to pay good lawyers
and lawyers in the UK are expensive and
the way the UK legal system is set up
you necessarily have two of them you
have your solicitor and you have your
Barrister so it's doubly expensive as
compared to the way we do it in the U.S
but you also need to think strategically
about what you're going to do and part
of what we're doing at the fund is we
are making sure that we are speaking
loudly and telling the community about
how serious these cases are
because these cases
are arguably the most serious legal
threat that the Bitcoin Community has
ever faced and even though each of these
cases is nominally about Bitcoin they
are more fundamentally an attack on open
source software and basic rights that
are as fundamental as freedom of speech
these cases are important for Bitcoin
and the broader Community but they are
also important to all of us who depend
on open source software in our
day-to-day lives so that's why the
Bitcoin legal defense fund was funded
and that I'm sorry it was founded and
that's what we're doing we're fighting
to defend these developers we're
supporting them in these lawsuits and we
are standing up on high and telling the
community pick your head up and pay
attention this impacts you whether you
love Bitcoin hate Bitcoin or completely
agnostic to it
how much of what you all are doing is uh
bitcoin's the Battleground but actually
this is about open source development uh
versus no it's just all about Bitcoin
and like yeah sure maybe there's like
some you know very dotted lines you
could draw to open source but that's not
really the the focus
great question
um it is exactly that these cases are
you know the Battleground is Bitcoin but
I think when you read the decisions and
you think about
what we are fighting about the court did
not narrowly tailor in the tool training
case the court did not narrowly tell her
its decision in a way that had any of us
walking out of there saying this has no
implications for anybody except Bitcoin
debts
the decision in tool train this
appellate decision which is now opened
this case up
for trial
was about the potential that open source
developers which Encompass Bitcoin
developers but also include Linux
Developers for example could owe
fiduciary duties to people that use
their code so that's what the tool
trading case is about the other thing
that's going on is that the MIT license
is on trial and I think that's a piece
that has not been getting enough Focus
but the MIT license is the most
popularly used open source license that
exists and when Bitcoin was first
developed it was released under the MIT
license and I think it's helpful to read
the language of the MIT license so I'm
going to do that now
the MIT license says that the software
is provided as is without warranty of
any kind Express or implied including
but not limited to the warranties of
merchant ability Fitness for a
particular purpose and non-infringement
in no event shall the authors or
copyright holders be liable for any
claim damages or other liability whether
an action of contract tort or otherwise
a rising firm out of or in connection
with the software or the use or other
dealings in the software the language of
the MIT license is incredibly clear and
it is this license and other similar
open source licenses that protect open
source software developers who release
their code freely into the world
that's what's on trial here that's what
we're fighting for and yes it is
nominally about Bitcoin but it is
clearly about the rights and the
freedoms of Open Source developers to
continue to work on free open source
software and offer it to the public for
the purposes of innovating and creating
our free our future
talk about the other cases that you all
are focused on and kind of working to
make sure that uh you you keep kind of
pushing forward here
so there's one other case that we're
dealing with and this case is uh at an
earlier stage this case is more
specifically it relies on uh Craig
Wright's fallback claim that he's
Satoshi Nakamoto I don't think it's
worthwhile to spend any time on that
allegation which has been proven of
other places to be fault I'm sorry false
but
very similar to the tool trading case
this again is an attack on open source
software more broadly essentially what
the allegations are in this place are
that uh Bitcoin developers and other
industry participants so there are some
big crypto companies that are defendants
in this case as well
um o a uh intellectual property rights
to the developer of Bitcoin and they are
infringing on these intellectual
property rights by
developing Bitcoin using Bitcoin
Etc it is a nonsensical claim but the
fact that this claim can even be
initiated in light of the language of
the MIT license is really scary
so
when you start thinking about these
licenses I and let me caveat this entire
piece with like I'm outside of my uh
circle of competence the second we start
talking about the licenses
um but but what I find interesting is
these are court cases that are happening
in the UK
but we are talking about licenses that
are from us-based institutions
how does geography play into this right
and would you actually prefer for these
court cases to be playing out in the UK
or the us or does it not matter
well I actually don't think these course
cases would have really gotten off the
ground in the U.S if you want my
perspective as an American litigator has
been doing this for you know more than a
decade
um I think there are several things that
made the UK jurisdiction
uh uh
palatable for Craig Wright he is suing a
lot of people who are not UK residents
and the courts were able to extend
extend jurisdiction over people who are
residents of the U.S and several other
countries
um in large part because of how the UK
legal system is set up so I guess at the
outset I I don't think this would have
gotten anywhere in the US U.S there are
a lot of problems with it not least of
which one of the remedies that Wright is
seeking in tool of trading is they are
he is asking the courts to order the
Bitcoin developers to write a back door
into this software and in the U.S that's
prohibited compelled speech software
development is protected speech in the
U.S and asking a court to compel someone
to speak is contrary to our
constitutional rights so that was sorry
I'll get off my soapbox and answer the
question that you actually asked but the
interesting thing about this is that yes
although this case is proceeding in the
UK it is against men many people who are
not situated in the UK so at the outset
if anybody's sitting here thinking well
so long as I'm not developing software
in the UK I'm safe that's false because
the people who are subject to this law
school I'm sorry this lawsuit are
situated all over the globe the second
thing that I think is really interesting
about this is
by its nature software is available
everywhere right so these open source
software developers no matter where they
are they're writing code that may at one
point be accessed by somebody for
example in London and that that's
somebody in London May then make an
allegation that oh no I was injured as a
result
of the code that you wrote you now have
to come to court in the UK to answer to
me so I would say that if anybody is
considering this as a UK issue or then
the confines of some sort of
jurisdictional world that's false
because the people that are being
impacted live all over the world and the
people that could be impacted by such a
decision
live all over the world so it's a bit of
a fallacy to think that this is you know
this is a UK problem this is a global
problem and I think it speaks to
um a larger Global Trend that we are
looking at which is sort of this
expansion of potential liability against
software developers so other things that
are going on that you know the fund
isn't isn't
fighting
um but I think it's it's worth
mentioning so that everyone's aware that
this isn't just happening because Craig
Wright has brought these from those
lawsuits against these devs there are
um there's legislation that's popping up
all over the world that seems to include
potential liability for software
Developers for certain types of harm so
for example there's a cyber resilience
act in the EU there's the AI act in the
EU there was the um uh gosh I'm
forgetting what it's called but it was a
Biden strategy report here in the U.S
that was released a few months ago all
of these things are sort of painting a a
picture of a trend we are moving in this
direction of trying to create some sort
of ad hoc class of individuals who
should be liable when a bad actor does
something bad and that's not really that
seems like a uh ignorant and
short-sighted solution to a problem
so we've talked a lot about open source
developers here if this was not open
source would these attack vectors be
available or would they have to
basically go and make claims against a
company or or you know some sort of
legal entity and the individuals
themselves will be shielded but that
would take away you know kind of the
trade-off being the the benefits of Open
Source
yeah that's it's exactly right
um if if this were for example
proprietary software the Avenue would be
to sue the company that releases the
proprietary software and that company
would Shield the employees that may have
developed that proprietary software
um so it would be you know the argument
be that the company would be on the hook
not the individual employees who may
have participated in writing the code
that was then
misused down the line but in that
example that analogy I think what's
interesting is if you were to if you
were to propose that you know uh Joe
schmoe sues Microsoft claiming that
Microsoft owes people a fiduciary duty
people be like well how what and what in
what world is there a link there
in the same way that there's no link
between you know these individual
software devs who who uh volunteer to
write open source source software and I
think that's an important point is that
this is volunteer work and in particular
for people who work on uh Bitcoin core
they don't receive any sort of direct
remuneration out of the work that they
do they work on bitcoin core because
they believe in it because it's an
interesting project and many of these
software developers also work on other
open source projects for example one of
our devs has been uh is a very prominent
software developer
um and he's one of the people who has
helped develop the audio codec that
these video chats use so like what we're
using to talk to each other at least
partially runs on open source software
97 of all the world's software has some
open source components Facebook's data
infrastructure runs on Linux the first
humans launched into space and SpaceX
were sitting on top of a rocket that ran
on open source course the most popular
smartphone operating system in the world
Android is open source the NASA's
technology that
figures out if meteors are going to hit
the Earth runs on open source so anybody
who thinks that this is sort of like a
narrow problem a Bitcoin problem a
problem that doesn't impact them or
affect their lives is not paying
attention to how threaded open source is
with our day-to-day lives
when you go into a courtroom and you're
talking about highly technical topics
such as we're talking about here
how do you get the judges or the jury to
understand what you're talking about
right if they don't sit all day long and
think about technical topics I mean do
you really have to start kind of from
101 and build up and explain you know
here's how databases work and here's how
open source software works and kind of
walk them through the entire Journey or
is there some sort of uh maybe filtering
system within the legal uh kind of
scheduling that will put you with juries
and judges who have the technical kind
of basics down to be able to make these
arguments
well it's different from jurisdiction to
jurisdiction I guess one thing to note
is that in the UK they don't have juries
so the decision will be made by a judge
who evaluates the facts and evidence and
applies the law I love the UK but that's
weird
that's one of my
one of them
yeah yeah for example their use of s's
instead of Z's it's weird but you know
our UK Brethren but
um
there's also a difference in the UK than
from the U.S or at least I'm I'm a New
York lawyer so I'm very familiar with
the court systems here where you know
cases are typically assigned randomly
here it's just sort of like the next
judge up gets the case and I think
there's some benefit to that Randomness
in the UK my understanding is that the
judges are a little bit more subject
matter oriented so cases that are about
IP for example go to a judge who
practice IP law when they were a
practitioner
bottom the role of
is to to teach the court or teach the
jury they should not be applying any of
the information that they know coming
into the case to the case they should be
learning from The Advocates what the
facts are and how they apply so provide
being able to provide the technical
primer in a comprehensible way is a
really important skill and it's one of
the most important things in this case
it takes us back to one of your earlier
questions the question of
decentralization I think frankly that's
just a bit of a misunderstanding that we
will not have a problem clearing up for
the judge that Bitcoin is in fact really
decentralized and nobody controls it I
think that's something that we'll be
able to explain and the judges will be
able to understand
but that's part of our job to make an
assumption that the finder effect knows
or should know how any of this works is
in proper it's our job to teach them to
tell them to make sure that they have
all the information they need to make
the right decision
are we going to have the developers take
the stand are we going to have them have
to uh kind of articulate answer
questions cross-examination like I
almost I'm envisioning this and again
stupid American who just uh entire court
you know kind of thought process is all
around like what you see on television
and uh I can imagine a Bitcoin core
developer sitting up on the stand and
you're asking a bunch of great questions
and then all of a sudden Here Comes
somebody who's you know teeing off on
them and and being combative like is
that what we should expect or is this
more of kind of a a procedural type
thing and and it's more the lawyers are
in there and the developers aren't
actually showing up in person
so this is another difference from our
sort of Perry Mason like American legal
system
um one thing that that happens in the
U.S legal system is part of Discovery
people uh sit for depositions that's not
typical in the UK so even the pre-trial
work is uh it's it's less of what you
are used to here it's more document
Discovery letters written back and forth
between the lawyers submissions made to
court lots of arguments on the paper on
the papers but this case is going to go
to trial and the trial will involve
people taking the stand and testifying
as to the facts
a defendant is not obligated to take the
stand in their own defense that's really
the same thing here in the U.S as it is
in the UK so
um the question of whether any devs will
actually get up to take the stand
um it's not required and frankly I don't
think it's necessary I don't think
there's any information that Holy lives
within the
um knowledge base of the devs that would
require them to sit up there and be
subject to cross-examination I'll also
say that the legal system and the
lawyers in the UK are much more
polite and decorous than they are here
so our you know the what we're used to
these sort of hard-hitting aggressive
lawyers make people cry on the stand
that's just not how it's done there
yeah it's very interesting to think
about
um again from like the Western you know
American Viewpoint how different just
the preceding itself is and and
um I do Wonder
um
it sounds like maybe that is a
disadvantage for the Bitcoin legal
defense fund would you agree with that
or is it actually something maybe that
you think is helpful
I think it's helpful to have this
cross-jurious jurisdictional view we
have our attorneys in the UK who
represent our our clients then who are
there to make sure that we are you know
appropriately managing the case in a way
that takes into account the Norms of the
legal system over there but we have a
lot of defendants who are Americans and
I think it's important that we can sort
of support their perspective as well and
I think because this really is across
jurisdictional issue even though it's
only taking place in the UK right now I
think it's important to have that sort
of global oversight over what's going on
let's look across the world and see
where the trends are and see where this
these encroachments are happening and
let's try and shut them down because
they're problematic and they're bad for
all of us yeah talk a little bit about
um kind of your future plans uh with the
Bitcoin legal defense fund so we have
these two cases here you all are very
focused on them and and I think one
getting the word out you know that
they're happening to why they're
important through what the details are
um but but what's kind of the the Future
Vision and for you all in terms of what
you want to be doing
the fund was started to fight for these
devs
nice devs it has grown to fight Beyond
um these devs and fight for the future
of Open Source but in an Ideal World we
won't have to exist in a few work few
years we will have done our job we will
have
beaten Craig Wright won these cases
created you know important precedent in
the UK that shuts down any future
potential allegation that there should
be a fiduciary duty something that would
be you know dismissed immediately by the
court
if we do our job and if all of you help
us by talking about it by speaking to
your friends by donating to our cause
hopefully we won't have to exist we will
have one and we can you know
all of us can go back to our day jobs if
you will so that's my ideal future State
for the Bitcoin legal defense fund it's
hard to say now where we will be though
in a few years
before I let you go talk a little bit
about what people can do who are
listening or watching this
um are there things that they can do
around these specific cases are there
things that they can do with the Bitcoin
legal defense fund
um what's kind of your call to action or
or kind of direction of uh people who
get excited and say Hey I want to help
here what can they do
so the outcomes of these cases are not a
foregone conclusion if we all of us
don't rally Behind These developers and
mount a strong defense the UK Court may
decide that there should be a fiduciary
duty owed by open source developers and
that would be devastating for every
single person listening to this
we are here not just fighting for these
13 devs we are fighting for all of you
we are fighting for the future of
Bitcoin and open source we are fighting
for your fundamental freedoms whether
you know it or not if you're listening
to this you have skin in the game and we
need your support
what that means is
donate go to our website
bitcoindefense.org
spread the word talk about this tweet
about this post it on Reddit tell your
friends about it tell your family about
it
we need you to shout this from the
rooftops this is a community problem and
it takes engagement from all of you to
fight it so that's my call to action
I think that that is a very worthy call
to action Jess I really appreciate you
taking the time to uh explain what's
going on with these cases bring
attention to them and then obviously
continue with your work at the Bitcoin
legal defense fund to participate here
and help defend these developers where
can people find you on the internet if
they want to reach out if they have more
questions or they'd like to engage in
any way
you can visit our website and contact us
through there I uh surprisingly do not
have much of a social media presence but
we do respond to email
um we do have Noster you can reach out
to us there you can zap us if you'd like
to donate through that angle
um that's how you reach us that's how
you can get engaged and you can learn
more about our cases we have documents
up on our website we have sort of a full
explanation of what's going on and if
you really want to dig into the issues
you know please do please do visit our
website to learn more
um and we hope you know we hope that
you'll all are you're all gonna help us
fight this worthy cause amazing well
listen thank you so much for taking the
time to do this I learned a lot today
and I think other people will have as
well and so we'll definitely do it again
in the future
thanks